a season of change for the cincinnati
bengals 16 years marvin lewis was the
head coach they had that run of five
straight playoff appearances still no
postseason wins since january of 1991
chris and i look at this bengals team
and i see some talented players yeah but
man is it hard to get excited about them
at a time when we're excited about the
browns we're intrigued by the steelers
we try to respect what the ravens are
doing and then there are the bengals
they just feel like they are mired in
this malaise that that is kind of
descended on the franchise and they
don't know how to get their way out of
it well one way to get out of it is
change coaches and they hope that zach
taylor can come in and and really set a
new tone whatever that tone may be yeah
i don't know if there's a team really
flying under the radar more or you know
a team that people are just brushing to
the side more than the cincinnati
bangalores the big point though like you
said there's talent for a team that
nobody talks about or we don't want to
talk about and i get it because we have
zach taylor who's an unproven commodity
as far as a play caller or a head coach
so we kind of see that part of it andy
dalton's not exactly the most exciting
guy in the world at the quarterback
position but then damn you go through
the rest of the roster and you start to
hit some impressive football players joe
mixon i mean he's a top end running back
aj green still being in the fold there
you know tyler boyd at wide receiver you
get to the defensive side of the ball
and getting their secondary mic it's
talented i mean whether it's dre
kirkpatrick or drake kirkpatrick or
william jackson who i think is one of
the better corners in football you know
the defensive line still with geno
atkins and carlos dunlap and a lot of
other good football players too so to me
the talent is there there are going to
be a thorn in everybody's side you know
i really look at them as a team that can
be anywhere from six and ten to nine and
seven i don't know how you look at it uh
but it's just a lack of i guess sizzle
factor with that football team right now
and i guess the big thing more than
anything with the bengals is does andy
dalton still to save his job to become
the quarterback of the future or will
this be the last year of the andy dalton
era there in cincinnati
yeah as you were rattling off all those
names i'm thinking wait a minute they
got all these good players but they
weren't very good last year they were
six and ten last year and it early in
the season it felt like they could maybe
surprise some people but they just
weren't able to get it done and andy
dalton was a second round pick back in
2011. last year of his contract they
added ryan finley i know that's a guy
you really like in round four and maybe
ryan finley gets a chance to supplant
andy dalton and you know andy dalton's
been banged up from time to time maybe
he gets a chance to come in and play and
pull a lamar jackson where hey here i am
and i'm pretty good and i'm going to
keep the starter on the bench even when
he's healthy but they seem to be
ambivalent about andy dalton if they
weren't they would extend his contract
they want to see how he does in this new
offense under zach taylor i just feel
like this is a season of transition for
the bengals as zach taylor finds his
footing because the thing is yes a
three-year four-year contract whatever
it may be mike brown does not pay people
to not work you know we thought marvin
lewis was safe for another year because
he had signed a two-year extension at
the end of the 2017 season the reality
was it was a one-year extension with a
one-year option so they were able to
fire him and owe him nothing zach
taylor's gonna be there for a while so
this is that almost red shirt year that
scholarship year where you try to figure
out what you have and where you're going
and it begins and ends with quarterback
because it does it's hard to get it's
just so hard to get excited by this team
yeah the graphic we had up key editions
carrie winn and bw webb all due respect
to carrie wynn and b.w webb but that
doesn't get me excited about the bengals
no you're right they did nothing in free
agency that gets you excited i mean yeah
they you know they lost vontez burfect
uh i mean re-signed tyler iford darquez
dinard resigned preston brown re-signed
but yeah no major yeah they're keeping
more guys they're keeping more guys from
the six and ten team yippee yeah you're
right they are uh but i still think they
looked at their team like you said and
goes okay we feel like we have talent
here we know we're not going to win the
super bowl this year let's continue to
build uh yeah again i don't think
they're a playoff caliber football team
but i think they're a team that can
upset some teams playoff wishes in
december because of their talent have
done a good job of addressing the o-line
there in cincinnati but yeah ultimately
i don't know if there's enough
difference makers on the defensive side
of the ball and i don't know if i have
enough faith in andy dalton to get them
to the promised land or the playoffs in
that way and i would ultimately believe
that this is the last year
of the andy dalton era in cincinnati
i think the one thing about the bengals
and and this has been a theme that has
come up throughout the 18 years i've
been doing this
you know
you hear owners all the time and coaches
and gm's say that our goal is to win the
super bowl our goal is to run the super
bowl i feel like mike brown the owner of
the bengals is the one guy who
understands how you'll win in this sport
is make money and his goal is to make as
much money as possible there's nothing
wrong with that and i think he's at
least being honest about what's going on
here because only one team is going to
win the super bowl every year if that's
your standard for success you're going
to be upset almost all the time and in
the case of most franchises you're
always going to be upset but if your
goal is hey you know what we understand
this is a business we understand we have
to act like we want to win the super
bowl but bottom line is we're just
counting money here
then you're a winner and that's just
always been the reputation about the
bengals they just truly don't care about
winning a super bowl they care about
maximizing their profit which is fine
that's what every business does and
again at least they're they're somewhat
honest about it but it's hard to get
excited about the team at times like
this when it feels like they really
aren't trying to win a super bowl yeah
no i i get i mean i don't want to say
they're not trying to win it but they
certainly yes make some head-scratching
moves and we all question maybe how the
organization is run in general i mean it
seems almost on a yearly basis really
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports